but he's got the game on in the
chokehold fam
he's had two hoes for three years and
there's not been a hiccup
[Music]
what a deal people happy new year in
that
2021 2021 you know 2021 what a writer
thank god it's the first thing i want to
say
thank god what a write-off of a year
happy we made it happy we're all here
happy you guys are still here um hope
you guys had a
good christmas because depending on
where you are obviously in certain
situations with corona etc but yeah mom
glad you're still rocking with us we go
again 2021
bigger and better you know the vibes you
know the drill
yeah man just hope you guys hope you
guys are still going to stay with us for
the ride because
it's going to be good this year is going
to be this year is going to be oh man
this is going to pop this year is going
to be i'm right now i'm actually high
you know what i think you know i was
thinking as well
i just want to formally apologize
for last week's episode so you haven't
seen it yet yeah i've not seen yet
but he already knows what it was a
shambles
of an episode and i just want to
formally say you know this is not what
we're about
here at sng we're not the type of people
that get complacent
with their fan base and with the efforts
that you man put in week on week to
defunct with us
it wasn't good enough and we've been
letting it slip
that am i the [ __ ] was such a joke it
was such
a pathetic little joke that like it was
all fun and games at the moment
yeah okay i was just laughing it's okay
i was laughing because it's all funny
yeah but really interesting really and
truly it's not on
it's not on and uh you man deserve
better so uh we apologize
we'll be better we'll do better 2021 is
going to fly
we're going to be moving fast yeah
that's what i'm going to say
sng's going to be moving fast this year
so you might need to stay with it yeah
yeah
keep up catch up catch up because yeah
patreon's just moving
it is it is um we've got a few lives
lined up
on patreon um we've got some some fun
stuff coming
new merch rocking can you guys see the
gang gang
obviously minor things um
and yeah man we're just going to move
into shaking with you guys so can't wait
um and was there anything else oh we've
got an unboxing to do
oh let's do that now first unboxing oh
wow so a lovely
subscriber lovely fan i should say fan
fun
fan fun fantasy yeah fern's a incredible
artist based in birmingham
so the box is huge so i'm not really
going to bring it on
yeah we can't even put the box on camera
because it's so big she did
a i'm assuming it's a painting we have
no idea i've no idea she's done some art
for us we have no idea what it is
we we've had it for how long have you
had it a month three weeks
two weeks three weeks maybe
and we've not been allowed to open it
because she her one request
was that we just opened it on on the
show so imagine this isn't her box
imagine if it's just a package for you
emma
imagine imagine if her thing never
arrived and you're just about to whip
out
dildos i knew you were gonna save dildos
oh you're such a kid you're about to
live out dildos
i will gasp oh my god
bear with me guys this is awkward to say
at least
not playing this is i'm excited when bro
when you sent you know what it was here
when you know when you sent me the
picture of the box when it arrived
yeah i thought the ting was flat i
couldn't see the depth of it
so i thought oh it looks big but it
looks flat yeah this box is massive
i don't know what she's painted
man said dildos imagine if it's uh
like a collage or just ask us just naked
together
imagine though because some people would
like to do great like crazy art
one time my brother one time my brother
for his bedroom's birthday the reason is
the reason i brought it up i was gonna
yeah one size
one time for my bedroom's birthday yeah
because my brother's like his boys are
like a group of three right
okay my brother and two of his boys they
all live together okay
one time one time for his boy's birthday
yeah
he commissioned an artist to do
a portrait of
my brother and one of his housemates
riding they may have been naked riding
naked
horseback and the horse was
the guy whose birthday it was but he was
a centaur
so half man half horse and they were
just in a forest
fam funniest painting i've ever seen
funniest painting i've ever seen is it
is it hung up in their yard
i think so no i don't know if it's hung
up it's not public in the earth it might
be in my man's room
i think is it yeah who's this birthday
was it is he they're called jeremiah it
was even
i think it was joe's birthday i think he
was the center where matt was just
behind your brother was your brother's
behind
riding [ __ ] see obama was right at the
front
matt was riding [ __ ] holding his waist
[Laughter]
all right you ready i'm excited bro pop
it open
let's get it drum roll please guys
oh there's paper in there there's paper
in there bless her
bless her
is there more than one yeah oh i think
she may have done
multiple multiples like because
obviously we said yeah
my favorite one in your favorite social
oh no and she's right
individually wrap them it says this is a
merry christmas
merry christmas guys we have amazing
fans
you open that one it says merry
christmas on it
nah there's more there's one here
oh my god come hurry up please
oh my god what's that
she's dead that's actual christmas
present there's an actual sweet these
these are
this is like roses or qualities
throughout that nice guys stop it you
man stop it
stop it fern needs to stop
yeah there's another one
what's that i don't know james head is
heavy you've got strength that's honey
you go straight you pass it to me like
it was just changed
oh my monster
that's the second monster we've spilt
today i'm sick you know what yeah
it's it's a new year's a new me it's no
it's not
it's not sick as last year i'm sick
today
i'm about to throw the box away as well
imagine if there was little sketches on
it that's what i was going to say
is that everything
i think all right i think so all right
i'll deal with that later
i know what this is okay hang on let me
open this one first what do you think it
is
do you want me to say what i think it is
yeah it's heavy family yeah i i know
like a boston team i think is monster
a monster an individual no it's too big
to be a monster oh that's a monster
so she probably got you a case someone
said these are probably sweets because
she doesn't love sweets
hang on right you open them
tight very tight um audio listeners i'm
so sorry by the way yeah audio listeners
i hope you're with us
i like this one they're sweetie sweeties
as well
i don't know if you might concede it's
fun thank you
mango loco i'm going to treat i just i
just built one of them just built one as
well
a mango loco and i was thinking i need
to buy more sweets to fill up the jar
spud me fun's about it let me read the
card as well oh is that a card
yeah yeah my mom used to cuss me when i
was a kid and i didn't read the card
first do you see me searching for my
card
because there's james and foo had on it
thank the lord
for me because i was looking for my card
under the box cuz oh my days
james and foohad i hope you guys love
the artwork take care love burn
gang thank you thank you so much thank
you so
much thank you let me bust this loco
that's made my year it's crazy right
this is made
in my year we actually get gifts from
people ah
gang as if she gave us it's actually
individual treats it feels cold
that looks the box looks good at the box
the [ __ ]
try it try it mango look is because this
is a sugary one i don't usually do the
sugary ones mmm
i love mango as well
it's nice it's actually really nice it
is good i like this one
all right presents time again audio
listeners so sorry for this
long list but it's not long enough
send our sign in wherever yours send us
yours oh that's funny
i don't want to ruin it wow
don't show me don't show me yourself
first yourself
i'm i feel like a kid i feel like an
absolute kid right now paint paint
oh my stays bruh
you know what's weird we actually got
the cause it's exactly what i said what
i thought it was
i'm assuming it's your two and yours are
mine two on mine
it's my assumption i'm coming today
you've got the right ones no no no
cause i couldn't see it one of mine on
one of yours oh
and then and then one of yours on one of
mine
this one's amazing are you sure yeah
this one's amazing
who did i pick i picked his soccer and
who you picked uh netero
netero guy from hunter yes i might we're
both from hunter brexit
i picked rock league rock clies on here
and you picked a soccer right
as well oh show me yours and i'll show
you mine that's what she said
the colors the colors the colors show
the fans show the fans
i don't know how much you can see now
the colors on that is
bad show me that again are you ready
i'm ready pull it up oh that
yo that is sick
guys obviously you know we love our
anime
but wow while she's in rio on the back
yeah
wow yo fam this is one of the best
i want this in my yard fam wow
wow this is unbelievable unbelievable
i'm putting it up now
how are you getting it up i'm just going
to put it on here for now we'll sort
that out later guys but
it's not great because it needs to be on
that is absolutely fantastic that's
unfucking believable bro
jesus christ that
that artwork is the sickest [ __ ] i've
seen that's unbelievable
that's unbelievable thank you so much
wow make sure there's nothing left in
there please
i'm nervous just make sure there's
nothing in there oh i promise you
there's nothing left in there you see
the bottom of the box
yeah all right cool that's better all
right bless i'll check again later
thank you so much thank you so much that
is fantastic
unreal that's fantastic soccer looks
different
the shadows the netero and the bro the
whole tingling you're an artist
you're a real artist so yeah yeah um
you're an artist
wow i'm gonna pop the the link uh to
fern's instagram oh yeah for sure in the
in the description so
if you guys want some of that good hit
her up man hit her up please she's
wow that's insane wow
you're right i want that in my yard yeah
wow if this friendship thing doesn't
ever work out and we have to lock off
the pod
i'll be guest at least i'll have one
thing is that one of them is coming to
my office
ah i want netara though but i want you
want him
you know what i like about it what this
is stupid yeah
don't you think it encapsulates their
personalities as well
like don't you think the actual art
itself or the actual the
the picture yeah encapsulates the the
personality
of the character of course of course
that's amazing of course how innocent
does aang look in that thing
i kind of see it from here to be fair
he's
and how mischievous and crazy does his
soccer look and how nasty and powerful
does netaro look
and how up for it does rock glee look
brav brookly looks about it
if you might have never seen hunter
rick's hunter or naruto or
ang is from avatar that's what i was
looking for
um yeah definitely watch him because so
you can get more effort bro
but yeah unbelievable unbelievable
thank you so much thank you so much man
that was ah that was a great way to open
this great
start got a great start to 2021 to 2021
thank you so much
thank you for that and thank you for
telling us to wait to unbox it to unbox
it on the show
because that was a good feeling yeah
cause you would've popped it open that
your yard when it arrived
on the day on the day and you would have
sent me a picture nobody that's it and
we would have just moved on
right cool but yeah yeah that's ah so
good that has made my day bruv all right
let's get into the fun fact
oh yeah fun fact gang ah jeez
what a rush cool there's a chemical
compound used in vanilla flavoring
flavoring and scents come they come from
the anal gland of beavers
it's called castorium it's a substance
that is used by
it is the produced by the byproduct of
the beavers castor sac
which is found between the pelvis and
the base of their tail beavis use the
substance which is there
which is usually brown and sticky to
mark their territory
and it's the compound that makes
flavoring and sense
of vanilla comes from the sack of a
beaver
a chemical compound anal sat did you say
anal gland from beavers it's called the
cascasteria i'm a
custodian so artificial vanilla comes
from that
so these men are just marking their
territory with just vanilla
scent that's cool to be fair but that's
disgusting it's disgusting but at least
now you know
it's funny that actually brings me to a
point as well like someone um
hang on that's disgusting
mad but that brings me to a point that
like one don
message the other day um and was like
ah does james know that there's bull
semen in [ __ ] he commented the other
day on
youtube does james know this ball seaman
in monster there's not
just i didn't see that there's not let's
just get
he's on about taurine okay and taurine
is in
everything which is what was like coke
i should have researched before i know
what it is but it's not [ __ ] ball
semen
okay i think it's it's it's found in the
in this
i think in the stomach
i want to say it's found in the stomach
bile
of a of a cow
but it just made me think like when he
said it
he was like oh does he know he's
drinking black bull semen and stuff
and i was thinking it's your same with
your vanilla thing
considering what we eat on a day-to-day
basis
yeah if i did find out it was like
derived not obviously just
not nothing in a can but if i found out
there was an element yeah yeah yeah
like a small percentage like taurine in
here is what
naught point four percent naught point
four percent of this is taurine
so if i found out that 0.4 of my drink
was derived
from the testes of a ball is that enough
for me to just never drink it again
just like to find out the flavorings of
vanilla i found out in the anal gland of
a beaver
i'm like but i just back [ __ ] i eat hot
dogs and [ __ ]
i ate chicken nuggets fam that texture
ain't right can you eat a chicken nugget
that texture's not right i know what you
mean and i'm like am i that fussy funny
enough i saw someone
look look into a hot dog like they broke
a hot dog put it under a microscope
thing
yeah i saw it the other day hair galore
there's just hair all up in the thing
it looked like pubes it looked like they
rolled it on the floor and then put it
in the thing
disgusting very disgusting oh my day so
taurine
is an organic compound that is widely
distributed in animals tissues
is a major constitute constituent of
bile
and can be found in large intestines etc
there you go yeah so he's found in bulls
oxies blah blah blah yeah
do i give a [ __ ] not really bro cause i
back
balls from cows i back it all the time
steak the fat oh yeah the the connective
tissue are back at all so 0.4
is in my little monster man's thinking
i'm drinking that
get your face straight before you come
on my page get your fat straight before
you come on my age with the hype about
drinking bull nut because i'll expose
you but are you able to expose
that's hilarious that is hilarious but
yeah man
oh cool god have we got a fan request
today i've got loads of fun requests
oh i've uh i've got one that's probably
in your pile oh it's in my pile as well
this has got to be one of the juiciest
family quests i've ever heard is it all
i think i know which one it is but go go
you already know which one it is yeah
yeah
i definitely know which one is that you
said that but yeah go one of the juices
from
questions oh yeah rags her chest is
nonchalant fam
right cool so let's bring it up hi guys
i'm a big fan from cape town south
africa i'm 19 years old and i'm dating
two guys
the gang the main guy
and myself have been dating for almost
three years and the second one for eight
months
the second guy has no clue that i have
another guy gang
i'm currently studying psychology just
finished my first year and my second
boyfriend
just finished year 12. my plan is to
finish my studies and move in with my
main guy
however this is the best line i've heard
however he has a girlfriend and they've
been together for three years as well
let's put a pin in that come back to her
later i'm pinning that
come back on later i'm not really sure
what i should
uh what i should do oh yeah i'm not
really sure what i should do
continue both relationships or call it
quits with the main guy and only
focus on the second
wow wow right so let's do this
let's catch the normal debrief yeah
debrief cool
19 years old from south africa dating
two guys
main and side maine's been about for
three years
side for eight months everything's jolly
no one knows about the other
she's um finishing her studies
and wants to dilly dally with with both
of them until she's finished up
school work once she finishes up school
work
um she wants the bb with
maine in maine who's who maine
has his own main she's not even maine
she's not made to her name
she's a side to her main wow
tables this is domino's table's turn
fam wow and she doesn't know whether she
should lock
off mane because he's got a girl or try
and pattern a move-in situation and so
he can lock off his go and be with her
and she can drop number two or she
should just be with number two
this is palava you're not 19 why is that
my mouth you're
19 cuz i wasn't dealing with that when i
was 19.
it's so nonchalant for her she said it
was such
chest with such chest 19 i was
worried about [ __ ] exams in uni like
that's what i was worried about
19 i was stressed i did not have two
girlfriends fam
one of which who has another boyfriend
and one yet that's just oblivious
and i'm tossing i'm just tossing i'm not
even worried about getting found out
i'm tossing what what
what is going on what has changed in the
last 10 years
a lot clearly a lot clearly everything
everything 19 and i've got a three-year
relationship with a and i'm deciding
from a meeting and i've got a sighting
for eight months
what do i do
it's weird because if a guy asked me
that i'd probably have the answer
i don't know why i feel like because i'd
resonate not necessarily resonate more
because i'm not
i've never been in that situation but i
may have an answer for him you know i
mean
i figure out how we can balance the
thing but i feel like for a girl it
might be a little bit different
but it's just how do you get yourself in
that situation i want to know
obviously we're going to help you out
well we're going to try and help you out
but i also want to know
how you got yourself in a situation of
being with my man the first guy for
three years
and then still wanting another man and
then beaming him for eight months and
then juggling both at 19.
nah and no one's found out main guy must
be
older in my head main guy's older
because second
sightings younger in my head main guy's
like 35 years old
he's going to have to be and then
sighting is probably in the union in the
same
way he's in uh year 12
yeah yeah which means he's younger
younger she's 19 he must be 17.
so he's just probably grateful for the
pump that's why he's not asking
questions
damn main guy he's got his own he's got
his own
setup three years he's got a wife how is
that's what i need to know what
conversation was happening
because he's been doing it in three
years as well
his wife he's his main has been in it
for three years and this thing's been in
it for three years
oh he's had both hosts for three years
and nothing has come up
and this chick knows he's got a mane
and she knows she's the side i need my
man
in here teach lecturing us
he needs to teach the masses fam you
need to you might need to be sending him
am i the [ __ ] because he's clearly
going a lot he knows more than me he's
got it unlocked he's got he's got the
game
on in the choke hold fam he's had two
hoes
for three years and there's not been a
hiccup
and i don't know what his main knows
maybe she knows nothing maybe she knows
everything
but my girl knows everything she knows
everything but the main partner
his man can't know everything what i
want to know as well is that she said
the plan is
is that after my studies me and maine
move in how
he's got a misses how is that pattern in
how is that pattern and what happens if
it doesn't
what happens if he says nah
that's what i know what happens if he
says
now i'm trying to i'm trying to move in
with bae
i'm sorry but i'm not really trying to i
like what we've got going on i like
where we're at yeah what happens in that
regard and she's like i'll swear
i can't say mothers say mothers three
years
and she's wasting my time say well he oh
my days
oh yeah yeah we need she'll ruin the
whole we need
we need a re-up after we give the advice
we need to react because we need to know
what's going to happen
yeah because you can't how how how has
she gotten herself into that situation i
don't know
also off the bat yeah my recommendation
just forward thinking my recommendation
would probably just be with
um option b option b only because
nothing good can happen with being with
someone with with someone
when you've been dating for three years
while they've been cheating on their
girlfriend with you
oh rags for the same amount of time for
the same amount of time so when he drops
off his main
to be with you are you just gonna be
comfortable
thinking that he's never gonna do that
again he's a master at this
you think you're the first experiment
you can't be
you can't be the first puppy he's a
puppeteer she can't this can't be round
one he's done this before
right because he's got the game tight
tight
three years and everyone's
happy three years in and everyone's
happy that's impossible
that's him it's important possible he
must have a second phone
he must but even that's stressful
that's stressful i've had two phones at
one point one for work and one for like
myself yeah
and that's stressful yeah to be fair
that's too stressful we can't have two
friends
he must limit her to [ __ ]
i don't even know they can't be in the
same place like
obviously we've not answered the
question yet but we're just trying to
deep the whole thing she can't be in the
same
vicinity seem like you must be right he
must be older he must be like
far removed from her current life he's
not in her mix fam
he can't be he bucks her uncle maybe
he's a lecturer
or something like that maybe he's on
campus i know we're making [ __ ] up but
that sounds juicy
it doesn't it that sounds juicy that's a
plotline
he must be somewhat like how because how
did they meet he has
okay we're going for he's a lecturer
he's elected he's a
juicy he probably they've been running
for three years she's only been in uni
for two
so maybe they met on an open day maybe
she went to check out the campus
and they said they just they crossed off
maybe he was a tour guide sutton
i don't even know he's breaking rules if
he's elected
he's breaking all the rules he doesn't
give a [ __ ] oh he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's given a single fight
um oh that's juicy so yeah he's probably
not our lecturer anyway he's definitely
not
but
and he's been smashing my girl for three
years she's
she's on base in campus he drives out to
his wife's
in the evenings and weekends but
his nine to five is on campus so he
sneaks in for the lunchtime
he sneaks in for the lunchtime back
shots
that's that must be the sexiest setup he
gets solid
he that must be the sexiest setup ever
like i can't even ah
[ __ ] having sex at your job
day in day out between lectures between
lectures
and everyone's just stumped oh waistcoat
just scrambled up
bowtie twisted and he just rolls up he
pulls it yanks it up
trump trousers go down but he just
shuffles it down he doesn't even yank
this he just flips the skirt over
oh wait bang back shot sir
oh this gets his handkerchief and just
dots his small headphones as [ __ ]
dance is a game down pat
wow he's got the game a lot he does he
has the game unlocked mr lecturer you've
got the game unlocked well done
well played well played well played good
sir wow
um wow so yeah she has to lock him off
because that's never gonna he's never
gonna pound it
because it's it's a lose-lose whichever
one he goes for anyway yeah boy he's
talking about her to look
she looked back she i'm saying she needs
to look he i don't know what he needs to
do
she i don't know what i don't know what
he needs i don't think i can give him
advice
yeah he's up here he's up at echelon
he's not gonna listen to me
do you even know what oh you think i
should oh cause you know you know what's
up
because you're so smart in your little
studio you're going to tell me how to
live my life
these times i've got everyone tied up
he's clapping cheeks
but i think she should lock off a and b
oh yeah same thing because she's
she's she's working from a place of
unfaith the foundations of both
relationships is tarnished it's
tarnished
you've got [ __ ] foundations on both
sides yeah so like
it's never gonna work either way you
need to scrap it and start again
because regardless of let's say okay
let's say
you do move in with um option a and he
does leave his misses or whatever
like james said it's going to be based
on a live a foundation like you're
obviously you're obviously going to
think oh maybe he's going to do it again
or she
he might think oh she um you're going to
be messing around or she's going to mess
around kind of thing and obviously if
you go for option b
b is just a backup so you're obviously
going to be taking the piss out of him
or taking advantage of him it's not
going to be a proper relationship he's
probably not going to give you
what you want he's not going to
stimulate you so it's just it's just a
lose-lose
no one wants to make your side ting the
main thing
no one wants to make the side signal
because they they weren't good enough to
make it to maine in
the first place so he if he becomes
option a
he's just a rebound and you're not
really that interested you're going to
pick up on his flaws like that
oh you're going to be livid you'll be
looking for a new mate you'll be
sniffing for a new name you've been
looking for c
so yeah my honest opinion is as juicy as
this all sounds
scrap option a he's gonna move in with
his misses
scrap option b he's just
not good enough he's not good enough up
for what you want and then if you want
like a wholesome
relationship trying to move in with
someone you need to find it you need to
start fresh
you need to start off out of the uni new
environment cheating out your system
out of uni new environment new
environment wholesome man
and deal with it all right boom scenario
so let's say you are actually a lecturer
yeah and there's actually a thing in
like second year
yeah that wants to free up the naan for
you you're you're
you're your age now actually no no no
am i let's say you're 35. okay i see a
35
and you're a lecturer let's say you you
you teach
let's say you teach hmm
what could be fun fun but juicy fun but
juicy oh what's that what's that what
was everyone what does everyone take
what's that um what's that [ __ ]
course that everyone takes
um the the lecturers get all the [ __ ]
it's uh philosophy
in movies they always teach philosophy
if they're smashing students they teach
people
philosophy first day they they pick up
their book and then like this is what
your exam's going to be
and they tear it up and they're like
[ __ ] the exam and then all the ass just
[Applause]
what lesson is this welcome to
philosophy one-on-one
on the chalkboard
writing calligraphy i launched the chalk
i'm like stand up stand up we learn
stand up here
[ __ ] these tables this is all a social
construct
that's more than just one yeah go
philosophy 101
first day there's um there's like
a room 30 people 20 guys there's about
10 girls but five of them are banging
five of them are banging but let's say
five of them they don't know each other
they're like dotted around the room
but they're all looking at you they're
all thinking oh who's mr duncan
you know when they call you mr duncan
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i miss them
when everybody's
stuck i turn around just glasses sick
and she does the glasses
she just crosses that you can see the
table under the table's head
and you can just see across the legs on
over under the under the desk and i'm
just like
[Laughter]
i'm here for it continue oh okay class
ends now you you've already
because obviously you know as a man when
you look at someone you know when
someone has a thing for you
as a it's just a norm
do i this is why this is why you're
where you're at and i'm where am i
anyway let's say you know what to do
yeah let's say i can just see it you
could just suck it up yeah
so sweet so
um end of the end of the class now um
let's say they have to leave out their
books or stuff or their um their books
on the tables and stuff you have to pick
them up
you open up the books from like let's
say you see two other girls
open up her book she's left a note it
says
hey mr duncan lovely first class
lovely to meet you my name is xyz here's
my number
and you just that's all it says
obviously that's all i said because you
don't know what's going on you're a
teacher fan
yeah the other one says hi mr duncan
101 was great i taste better
here's my instagram yeah
as you're speaking i'm not looking at
your face i'm reading the book
matt's got the glasses just reading my
pinstripe pants are tightening
and i'm just um okay
two hours in the first class first class
i've made it
i've made it you pre you pre the thing
on instagram so this
girl b now you found it instagram you've
gone through it or whatever but you
clock
that her older brother is someone you
knew
from back in the day and he's around
your age okay he's around your radar
okay but the other one is she still come
but you have to
bella you have to text her there's no
insects she didn't give you instagram so
it's a number thing
yeah obviously that's a bit more sticky
you shouldn't be here yeah yeah yeah i
shouldn't
i shouldn't that's forbidden
that's what we like oh
so what are you doing that's a breach of
contract
um that's the breach of law that's a
breach of that's an abuse of power
i shouldn't be doing that at all um
jesus everyone's legal everyone's
everyone's
exactly it's the social construct cool
cool cool cool which one are you going
for
and why which one i have to go with
someone you have
like don't necessarily have to but i'm
not married i'm single and i'm ready to
freak out yeah because obviously they're
in your class so they're gonna try and
egg you on
do you know what i mean they're just not
gonna quit they're not my head
they're not quitted in my head yeah
they're not stopping they're not going
to stop
even though i've only got this one
example of this happening in my head i'm
like they're never going to quit
until they receive the pipe they're
never going to quit so now
okay and and option a so the one that
gave you the number let's say she's
five three yeah thick oh god
five feet thick like a good thick
and a cross between like swiss and asian
oh my god yeah yeah carry on and
option b that said i taste better here's
my instagram but you know her brother
is also let's say five four five five
not thick but nice slender curly hair
piercing eyes nose ring
she's a [ __ ] nose
her legs are soft you don't even touch
me just know her legs are sliding off
each other
as she's crossing them you got to pick
one
a nose ring and nipple piss can send me
under yeah cause i'm thinking
i want the handkerchief beat do i mean i
want the nasty nast
so i'm probably going to go with that
one okay nose bring your nipple piece in
yeah open blouse
i'm yours
and you're talking taste i taste better
it tastes better better than philosophy
101
but you know her family bro oh yeah i
know her brother i completely forgot
about my name
older brother again that is sticky
i know you you forgot you but that makes
it more forbidden of course
i knew him or i know him and obviously
you knew him but
we've got we've got each other on
socials and that um let's say you do but
you don't you don't talk but you just
know that you know each other you know i
mean like if
she mentioned uh you to him
oh yeah james i know edc do you know me
jesus christ because she tries to look
she obviously knows your instagram she
searched for it
and it pops up our mutual it's her
brother yeah okay
that's how i know i'm like oh [ __ ] uh
hmm
good question bro this is actually a
sticky one
because i'm still leaning towards the
brother thing
but other ones sound banging and there's
a spanish teacher down the road
there's a spanish teacher down the class
down the hallway from
she's on to you she's on to you another
teacher another
teacher's on to you bro spanish thing
miss fuerte
mountain oh god and she's just she's
just flamboyant
always wearing shirts always wears
dresses open toe here everything just
accent
banging i'm banging her i'm banging her
but she has a husband yeah
let me finish let me finish you haven't
turned to me yet
she's got a husband and she's also
a faculty member like in the sense that
she knows waguan in the school
yeah yeah do you know what i mean yeah
you know what yeah
so okay go on so wrap it up
you can either [ __ ] option a
five foot three tick tis ask the works
filth and she's giving you but she's
giving you a number so you have to
follow up
your number yeah option b five foot four
i know option a is half swiss half tie
by the way
option option b mixie curly hair tongue
piercing
nipple piercing and she's just down
because she says she tastes great
and then option c is the spanish teacher
arse is just
insane flat stomach but she's a faculty
member she knows why i'm going to school
so
let's say you do pick a or b there's a
possibility she might find out
okay cool right i know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna take this instagram home and
i'm going to fap
i'm going to take the imagination of
what could happen
and i'm going to wank it all away yeah
and then i'm going to block her on
instagram
and i'm going to bang the spanish
teacher that's what i'm going to do okay
so what happening in these students okay
so what happens in
next week when you've got philosophy 101
again and they're trying again
because you said five minutes ago
they're not gonna stop you said it
yourself
so you said i could see it now they're
not gonna stop
ah i'll get lost in it man would it
you won't even have your what's the word
let me before you won't have your
syllabus ready you won't even know what
the [ __ ]
my papers will drop on the floor i'll
come in next session i'll come in you
know when they're holding all the papers
and they strip and they're all over the
floor and then i'm just like what is
going
on and i'm like god i'm not sweating
next week they're both coming they're
both sit at the front other ends of the
thing
we're in the skimpiest outfit
i would have to convince myself james
you can either make a move now
um i would just i'll get post nut
clarity
tattooed on my forearm fam and just like
you don't want to do it because
yeah it's just your imagination is
running wild yeah yeah yeah
once you're not you're gonna regret
everything yeah yeah
but you can keep banging the spanish
teacher as long as you want
and it's all gonna pop true and you can
keep this fantasy that these two are
down
and my entire semester is just filled
with the what ifs
you're so i've got spank bank material
for the year
yeah or i can ruin it and i'm i'm
fearing losing my job
forever for one night i can't never work
in school again
in uni again whatever yeah no i can't
let that happen so it's bad is teacher
spanish teacher
sponge teacher yeah i'm mad at science
teacher all of that is stressful
all of that is stressful that is too
much
who are you picking right so what i'm
gonna do
is i'm gonna [ __ ] the spanish teacher
that day
the day that i realize she's onto man
and it's established same scenario
i'm banging a spanish teacher next day
i'm heading to my notice and i'm
[ __ ] the share of those two students
i'm handing him under your 28-day notice
before your four-week notice
and i'm banging him i can get a job
elsewhere because
i don't need philosophy fair play i
don't need it neither do you don't move
your job just to nut
wow to be fair i don't know why i'm
asking you i know you i know a silly
question rhetorical question
i know you would i would not inside both
of them on separate occasions obviously
unless they were both down but yeah
jesus
straightforward from i ain't got time
toward
you can't you can't you can't do that to
me do you know you can't put me in that
position and expect me not to comply
i'm only a man you're a sex addict this
is what you are
sorry guys
oh you are you actually are that's funny
you actually are because i i've always
known i love pun
yeah i love pogba yeah it gives me a
spring in my step
and this story you're telling me it's
just it's imaginary and it's just
lightening my mood
it's lightening my mood for this
imaginary scenario yeah for me being a
lecturer in cape town
[Music]
it's literally just lifting me relaxing
the way your mind works there was never
a
option a b or c is how do i pattern all
of it and i'm willing to lose
everything i have to get it
that's addiction that's addiction
bro there's no two ways about it oh
that's so funny i'm willing to risk it
all
okay now that we now that we've got the
last out of the way i'm obviously not
gonna [ __ ] them
i want to say that because obviously it
was funny yeah but i'm still funny i
have to [ __ ] that sweaty [ __ ]
but okay okay if i'm being actually
realistic i will find a way to fight
these students i don't know how
the thing is because i'm not in a
situation i'm not in a situation i'm
only
as far as my mind can tell me yeah i
mean because i'm making this up
but i guarantee you i'm finding a way
bro i'm finding a loophole
the day i open that first book i'm
taking the picture and sending it
straight to you
i say i'll say the taste better thing i
will send you a picture of the note
screenshot her instagram cindy you'll
tell me to do the worst thing
of course because if you ain't doing it
i am well
ah you'll be telling me this who needs a
foot on her throat fab
let's go let's go let's go you have to
what are we waiting for i don't even
know how you said it
how does she taste tell me oh
i really love i know about diving into
like sex a bit more
um but i really love sexually confident
women like oh who doesn't
obviously everyone does but a lot of
a lot of women okay let me let me
rephrase and start again i'm not going
to say a lot of women because obviously
i don't know all women
but certain women i have been with in
the past
some do and some don't but are very
sexually
confident yeah they're just like they
just take control of the room
and as sexy as that sounds
they're also what's the word i'm looking
for
submissive of course yeah it's like
how they basically them how they balance
both so juggling that i'm not even
willing to comprehend it
let them do their masters in their own
right it's it's uh
that's what i'm saying like the yeah um
the instagram and the number thing like
that's such a bold move oh it is
obviously you as the student there's
only so much risk you're taking
because you can deny to the cows come
home that's him that wasn't me fam you
don't know whose book you're reading
that's not my number
it might be my number do you know me but
anyone could have written that yeah
but that kind of bravado wouldn't force
me to [ __ ] you this is you know
something that messaged us which one it
was um
it was a fan request not long ago yeah
that was a um her lecturer
she didn't know he was gay or not that's
her only worries
because stage b is she's getting that
dick
whether he's gay or not she just needs
to suss it
i could have she was confident with it i
couldn't be that extra
if you're a buff male lecturer and
you've got yats in your school
yeah it's in a factory it's long for you
do you remember in californication that
was hank in it do you remember in
california i
love californication it's probably my
favorite series of i've watched it three
times oh he
bangs in that show californication hank
is the nobody
bangs into this three best shows of all
time he nuts and he doesn't even want
it's a hassle fear he wants his wife
from him he wants his wife and child
just wants love fam he wants his wife
and his child and he just gets
[ __ ] thrown in put him in a sticky
situation he's gonna try
and try him he ducks and dives when he
can but sometimes he just can't
hack moody got women as well
he got women if you've never seen
californication watch it because i know
a lot of you guys
watch the stuff we recommend which is
gang and because i saw that some people
started watching community because we
recommended it which is gang as well so
sick i love community i'm re-watching as
we speak californications
definitely re-watch kind of i'm pretty
sure it's on netflix if it's not find
somewhere californication
just a quick synopsis for guys uh and
girls that are interested
is literally a guy he's an author
and he's just a general unassuming guy
who's moderately attractive but
his life is just chill he just wants the
easy life
he wants his wife and he wants his
daughter and his wife he's basically
separated from his wife she's moved on
she's got new man new husband new life
and his daughter and all he wants is the
happy family life with his wife and his
daughter yeah but whilst he's on these
streets
he's just gonna he's gonna smash yeah of
course but more time like he'll get
pumped thrown at him
and he'll be like oh come on man but
these girls are desperate to bang him
there's and it's where he's close to
getting his missus back or something
similar yeah yeah he's supposed to get
in the the life he was the life he wants
back and then
just railroads and then there's just a a
[ __ ] actress or something would just
throw nine at him and he'll ah for god's
sake and bang her and then his wife will
just coincidentally walk walking
and he'll blow up come on i didn't ask
for this i didn't want this poem
and we're not even together and she's
not even vex but she's
it's always at the point where the wife
is contemplating get back
every time she's contemplating but she
won't let him know that she's confident
oh yeah rags of course
in her own head she's like i miss him i
actually do miss him let me go visit him
she'll go visit him walk into his house
for some reason
and he'll be getting sucked off and she
blocked great
i knew it i knew it this was everything
together like big man it's not my fault
i love californication i love
californication
he lived the life in that show he lived
a life californication entourage
i probably
um and
yeah it's an interesting one okay
i'm gonna premise this by once i've
given this one
i'm going to already i never do this but
i'm already going to premise the fact
that next episode
i want to get into
this whole
kind of simply kind of [ __ ] mentality
that we've seen since we started this in
terms of men and women
okay because i think i said it a few
episodes ago in that
um whenever we get am i the [ __ ] and
fan requests and stuff like that
if anyone's acted up in terms of like
heartbroken and
yeah oh i've been cheated on i want to
give it another chance you think it'd be
the women that send those in
we've never had one woman one like that
true it's always the dudes always
that's very true and i'm like what's
going on broth who are these what is
always guys so i'm thinking in terms of
like
breakups and and heartbreak and all that
stuff i'm i'd love to for us next
episode to get into a conversation about
men versus women what's the difference
why is this happening why are we getting
all these messages
from okay but this is the cherry on top
okay hit me cool
so hey guys i'm a huge fan i've been
listening since episode 25 and you guys
are so funny thank you sir
thank you am i am i the [ __ ] over the
summer there was a girl that i fancied
but she had a boyfriend that was an
[ __ ]
i told her she's your opinion i mean
true
i told her she should dump him because
he's not good for her
and he wasn't i hate when people do that
anyway
pain in it and when she did
i confessed i liked her and she said she
liked me
excuse me plus and she she and she said
she liked me
but when we were supposed to hang she
said she would pick me up
and hang but then she decided to hang
with her ex
and he sent me a pic of them to cuddling
pin
so when i confronted her about it she
said
i told him not to send those pictures i
then said
that it doesn't change anything and she
shouldn't have lied to me
she said she would never see him or hang
with him again and the next day they
were in bed together
i've not seen this one was just sent to
you this one was my own personal okay
it's a rare it's a rarity so when it
happens
boy the next day they were in bed
together the next
day next day she has zero respect
she just done said it's never gonna
happen the next day she stepped on it
changed her mind
right literally slept on it um i'm not
the type of person to make a girl
dump someone for me unless they are bad
for them
after about a day or something a bad
person wow opinion
after about a day or so of thinking
about it i broke it off of her
and told her to kick it am i the [ __ ]
for doing that
for what doing the last bit nah what's
his name
let me expose you cuz now what
what what have you just read out to me
the whole thing and man wants to know if
he's an [ __ ] for the last bit
for leave enough for locking off and let
her do what i think she's doing her
thing she's been doing her thing
she's not been doing you
am i the answer for just been in a rough
in the last minute and say crack on
she's been cracking on g alright fam do
do recap again cause there's so many
pins synopsis there's so many pins in
this
wow cool man so donny
liked it girl over summertime she had a
boyfriend at the time
who was apparently a prick so he
suggested to her
oh you should dump your your boyfriend
he's bad for you stop
never ever ever do that guys or girls
never do that don't ever
it just doesn't it just doesn't it
doesn't make you look good
it doesn't do her any good it's just
it's
really lame it's so lame it's such a
simple thing to do
it's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] thing to do
your boyfriend's really bad for you you
should dump him you should dump him
are you her sister cars are you her best
friend
and i'm not saying that
maybe the reasons i'm assuming you gave
him you gave her reasons as to why they
should break up but
she knows that you like her yeah you
know what i mean that's the thing you
it's not yeah it's not necessarily
it's not advice yeah it's not that you
shouldn't be giving her advice about her
relationship if you genuinely think that
but you have an ulterior moment not
exactly that's the word you've got an
arterial motive so stay out of it you
might say dump
him so be with me yeah it's not that's
never going to happen
that's never going to happen that's
friendzone chat boy that is friends
that's friend zone just mistake number
one continue
so he said yeah dump him uh he's bad for
you
cool we've established she dumped him
you told her you liked her she said i
like you too
you guys he got gassed gassed he would
have been gassed assed
she said cool um
let's hang out tomorrow so he must say
yeah let's hang out tomorrow she's like
gang i'm here for it i'll pick you up at
six
he's like bless six comes and goes
mms little picture message multimedia
thing
looks at his phone it's the boyfriend
cuddling up on my go sending my man pics
and when he confronted my god about it
he said what the [ __ ] is this
i was waiting for you six came and went
from i'm getting boyfriends from from
i'm getting messages from your
ex-boyfriend
would you mind cuddling and her response
was i told him not to send those
pictures bruv
so you're you're you're out here
you're out here my girl is cuddling
cuddling with her man it's not her ex by
the way she definitely loved it yeah
yeah yeah
they are together she's gone and not
only this is the thing as well
she's told donny that you like her
otherwise how would he know to send the
pictures of course he's told she is told
my man that you like her um
they're having a little giggle about it
and then my man took some pictures and
said to his girl i'm going to send these
to my man and she said no
stop pretending to try and get the phone
he said shut up and he sent it
at your expense at your expense and then
you got it confronted there she said you
know what
[ __ ] this guy you're right he's a prick
i told him to send those pictures he did
anyway i'm done with him i'm not hanging
out with him again
and you were like oh thank god next day
next day they're in bed
oh wait how do you find that they're in
bed together i actually don't know it
doesn't say i don't think he specified
they said the next day they were in bed
together i think he was too
too traumatized to even last yeah he was
his fingers were doing bits he wasn't
thinking he wasn't thinking straight he
was just going
typing she said she would never see him
again and the next day they were in bed
together so i don't know if she told him
i don't know if he got more pictures
i don't know if he got a video i don't
know how he got pictures he's not mad
enough to say yeah
he's not mad after he got more pictures
he's not mad enough to say because it's
an embarrassment
oh it's the top of it and my man said
i'm either yourself for locking her up
so she can do her thing
big man
i think this is not even enough this is
not even a mind this is not an animal
this is exactly this is not
am i the [ __ ] territory this is more
of a life lesson for you sir
you
you you're a simple you're a simple
human being you're a simp
there's there's no other way to put it
there's no other way to put it she's
taking you for a mug
um and what do they call what's that
thing called
what um you got um this is harsh but
you got chad's and you've got um chad's
her boyfriend's a chad and he's a um
why is my brain sort of [ __ ] he's uh um
there's people screaming at the screen
right now
it's basic fam there's chad's chad
meaning like hunks and yeah yeah yeah
and there's um in cells i have no way
you don't know what an incense i've
heard this before mothers i'm not you
can keep looking at me mothers i'm not
hurting before so i think it's playing
you can keep looking at me like that
yeah is uh in i think it is short for
involuntary
celibate oh wow so an intel is a is a
community of gentlemen
who cannot get [ __ ] just to pause you
even more that's
even worse that it's an acronym oh you
thought in cell was a word
no insult involuntary celibate
it's a bunch of [ __ ] old guys that come
together and they physically can't get
[ __ ] and they're mad
at alpha guys for getting all the [ __ ]
they call them chads
i've never heard of this bro this guy's
this is intel chat
how do you feel do you see how it is uh
no but i think he's young oh
man it's a life lesson bro
top intel behavior that but that is also
the most brutal
eye-opener oh you've been baptized in
fire
you've been baptized in fire
you've been scorched he thought these
hoes had good souls
he had no idea he had no idea what he
was
getting himself into wow rule number one
no
ever if you like someone don't ever
recommend they break up with their
boyfriend don't ever
do it ever don't ever want to do it
because like
even if she likes you from you doing
that from you being that shoulder for
her
yeah she doesn't want she's never gonna
want to [ __ ] you yeah she's not
she might think you're a nice guy but
she's never gonna wanna [ __ ] you
she wants to [ __ ] the douchebag that
she's been [ __ ]
because he's a man unless he's an
[ __ ] but he's a
man he's an [ __ ] he's a he's a
[ __ ] fan but he's a man he's a chad
there's a there's a there's a great uh
quote
um in um
[Music]
it was more like a monologue in team
america do you remember the film team in
america i've probably seen that once or
twice
yeah i know i've seen it maybe twice i
definitely remember that team america
fantastic movie but they talk about
uh they do this like weird analogy
between people and they call them
dicks [ __ ] and [ __ ] okay and they
were talking about like
you got three types of people you got
dicks you got [ __ ] and you got
arseholes
and everyone loves a [ __ ]
but [ __ ] get [ __ ] okay everyone
hates a dick because all they want to do
is run around and [ __ ] everything
but the good thing about dicks
is they also [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ]
need to get [ __ ]
um and it's a stupid little thing yeah
it makes perfect it does make perfect
sense all right now you're acting like a
[ __ ] bro yeah
you are and she wants she needs a dick
she just will see the [ __ ] just don't
worry i don't mesh
she needs a dick and she might not like
her dick
but he is a dick he is a dick and he's
gonna [ __ ] her
and she doesn't look at you and think
you're a dick ready to [ __ ] she sees you
of a bit of a [ __ ]
and a woman needs a dick so you're never
gonna
if you if you act like a [ __ ] no
offense i mean
i mean [ __ ] in the nicest way possible
but if you're gonna act a bit like a
[ __ ]
and do things that you might not even
think of bad things but they're just
[ __ ] things
they're in-cell simpy friend-zone things
where you're talking about like your
boyfriend's bad for you babes your
boyfriend's bad for you
like i'm out here i'm a good guy she
doesn't want the good she doesn't
clearly
she knows the difference everyone knows
the difference she doesn't want a good
girl she doesn't want a good guy doesn't
want you son
she wants to get choked out she wants
her throat stood on
she does she does she wants to get
spread out
she doesn't want a nice guy to do that
to her oh
just like nose ring tongue piercing
nipple piercing oh i don't want a
wholesome number
i want to say i taste fantastic come on
it's
fantastic i'm trying to drool
that's what i spit that's that's what
it's about that is what it's about she's
not she's not
and if she's yeah if she's she doesn't
want to
like break up with her man to be with
this like really nice
princely kind of guy if she's going for
a rebound straight off the back of her
man
it's gonna be it's gonna be even more of
a dick than our last man
yeah um and then maybe bro the t the cut
no offense
but the kind of guy you are you'll
really come into your own in about your
thirties
when women are tired of dick's name yeah
they've been had this yeah yeah yeah
maybe try a [ __ ] they're gonna settle
for something
[ __ ] up i'm trying to get entirely
[ __ ] over bruh let me try myself a
little bit [ __ ]
that's when you're gonna skyrocket
that's what you're gonna scare your
niche market is gonna die it's gonna go
your stocks gonna go up oh but for now
you need to be a bit more of a dick
you have to be you don't need you have
to you have to be and that doesn't mean
be a mean
person it just means be more alpha be
more of a man
like if she's out here with a with a
[ __ ] boyfriend hey if you want to give
her advice
and say oh your boyfriend sounds like a
prick give your advice and move on
move on not this whole i'm trying to be
i'm trying to be with you i like you
let's hang out like
i know you got a boyfriend but he's a
bad guy i'm a good guy like no i'm not
saying you said that but it's just like
that's the vibes you're giving
i'm i'm so annoyed
i'm picturing myself as the bra
speaking to her the day before saying oh
wagon for these pictures
and she's like oh yeah my bad i told him
not to send it i'm never going to see
him again and then the next
day next day knowing they slept in the
same bed and he blew her back doors out
next day the next day obviously he's not
he's not exposed he's not exposed to how
he knew he knew this yeah but it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter regardless how you
found out it's just i would have hung
myself
i would have hung myself damn i want to
cut my dick off because i don't need it
clearly clearly kill myself from a
curtain
that's tragic baptism of fire my man
and that's all right because you'll
learn from it now yeah definitely it's
not it's definitely not an am i the
[ __ ]
oh hell no it's not an amazing at all
hell no
it's something else it's it's not for
this show
it's not for this show this is for dr
phil for
us this is not for us why the [ __ ]
for locking her off
she's scum you've been locked off
you fam she told you twice she's not
about it
you don't want to hear it man said no
stop don't send the picture
that's too funny i imagine that that's
too funny she abused you
cause but let's learn though now you
know
women not necessarily when maybe her or
people like her or stuff that
that kind of thing like they just need
that alpha they need someone with
dominance you need to assert
and not assert dominance be like oh you
need to break up with your man and be
with me
because that's [ __ ] no woman wants
to hear that yeah exactly you just need
to be the man that you are man
just be the guy you want and just use
your strengths if you're a nice guy
use that to really be nice just be a
nice guy man but don't be the nice guy
don't be trying and be a nice guy for
her yeah
just own your strengths boy if you're a
nice guy let it work for you bro just be
a nice guy don't be don't be a nice guy
for [ __ ] just be a nice guy you will
get [ __ ] bro
it's like um it's like um like priests
you know we hear priests just like
scandal like there's always like a
scandal of like a priest just
banging out someone in the confession
box that whole thing is just like he's
this perfect
guy i need to [ __ ] this guy do you know
what i mean like he's this
unattainable perfect guy and i have to
[ __ ] him
like they're not out here trying to
console
man through like women through their bad
relationships be with me be with me i'm
i'm this i'm that
they're just out here being pure sure
just giving god giving good advice and
moving on with their life they're
confident in who they are
they're not out here for anyone else's
recognition or nothing from nothing else
just if you're a nice guy bro be a nice
guy use it to your advantage and trust
me
someone's gonna be sitting in your face
but for now i've had my face out in a
while
but now we'll talk about that on patreon
oh yeah twice a month now so yeah
um first on the 5th and the 15th so yeah
guys tune in man
um but yeah bro you're not the [ __ ]
it's a silly question um
for blocker and everything and unless
yeah you need to move on you need to
move on let's get this dub because you
just took the hardest oh i've heard
that's the hardest i've heard this is
episode 71
one yeah in 171 we've not been doing of
71 episodes but yeah i'm at the also
this is the you
this is the biggest one we've seen and
you're not even in the also you're just
this is a terrible
it's just a terrible l your your stomach
is sore cause
and just yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
her [ __ ] her man
let they deserve each other bro just
move on and you got this on the next one
one of them one sorry bro yes
i'm actually sorry sorry bro anyway
let's wrap it up uh yeah man see you
guys next week
uh fun thank you for the artwork we're
gonna plug you
i'm gonna shout merch in the description
patrol in the description
yeah man um happy new year again and
yeah
look out for more match